Hey guys, in this video we're going to talk
about how to fix hypoglycemia, all right?
Now, what is hypoglycemia?
Hypoglycemia is a situation where the blood
sugars go too low.
Normally in the body you should have blood
sugars of 100.
What does that mean?
I'll give you a little comparison.
If you were to weigh let's say 180 pounds,
you'd have about a gallon and a half of blood
in your entire body.
The amount of sugar that would be diluted
in there to equal 100 would be about one teaspoon,
so it's really very small amounts of sugar.
And it doesn't mean you have to eat sugar,
your body can make sugar from other types
of things, like protein, even fat.
So it's not that you even have to eat any
sugar at all.
But the point is that we need this normal
blood sugar to maintain fuel in the body.
Okay, it should be 100.
When it drops down below 70 that's when you
start getting the symptoms of hypoglycemia.
Brain fog, cravings for sweets, anxiety, fatigue,
shakiness, weakness.
It's kind of like if you have kids, you know,
and let's say you're bringing them grocery
shopping with you when they're hungry and
tired.
They're going to experience all these, specifically
irritability, right?
And that's how low blood sugar ... And they're
just going the go a little crazy on you.
The point is that when those blood sugars
crash it pushes you out of the present and
you don't think rationally, and you'll eat
things that you end up regretting.
Here's what happens, and this is the problem,
is that the doctors, the medical profession
is telling people to keep some candy in their
pocket, or glucose tablets.
In case your blood sugars run low, go ahead
and take some candy and bring 'em back up.
And these are even diabetics.
They're looking at this problem very superficially.
It's kind of like if you stub your toe, and
well here, just take a pain pill every time
you stub your toe.
But like, why don't we just look at why you're
stubbing your toe in the same spot?
The why is this: if you're taking medication
and it's spiking it ... insulin too high and
your blood sugars are coming down too fast,
it could be that you're taking too much medication.
You just need to lessen the medication.
Rather than try to correct it at the blood
sugar level to add more sugar into the mix
which will create more problem, why not just
take a little less next time to even it out.
That's one solution.
Next solution is to get out of the diet what
triggers this in the first place, and I have
a ton of videos on that, I'll put them down
below.
You know, the sugars, refined carbohydrates,
and things like that.
But I want to tell you an equally important
thing.
It has to do with the opposing hormone to
insulin.
Insulin reacts to glucose, and what it does
is it lowers blood sugar.
So there's a hormone that does the opposite,
and it's made by the pancreas.
Insulin is made by the pancreas, but this
hormone is also made by the pancreas too,
and this is the missing piece and I'm going
to explain why.
It's called glucagon.
Glucagon, okay?
So that kind of does the opposite of insulin.
So if insulin lowers blood sugars, glucagon
raises blood sugars.
What it does is it mobilizes and releases
stored sugar from your liver and even the
muscles.
So you have this thing called glycogen that's
stored sugar, glucagon releases that to keep
the sugars constant.
You have this constant thing where your insulin
and glucagon are working together, all right?
So now here's the question.
Why don't we just increase glucagon instead
of eating candy?
Why don't we do that?
Well, because people don't really understand
what triggers glucagon, so I'm teaching you
right now.
The main food that will trigger glucagon is,
ready for this?
Protein.
Moderate amount of protein, not a lot.
You just need a moderate ... between three
to maybe five ounces of protein.
Protein will trigger glucagon, and I have
a little story.
I had blood sugar issues when I was very young,
and then one day for breakfast, I would normally
have a carbohydrate breakfast, I decided to
have some protein.
And it was like a switch.
I instantly like could think again, I was
feeling so much better mentally.
I was clear, I wasn't all foggy like I used
to be, ant that was because of this situation
right here.
It brought it up normally.
The point is if you're doing a very low protein
diet, and you're not having protein with each
meal ... and I'm not saying have a lot, just
a little bit, especially in the morning if
you're going to have breakfast, then you could
be having this hypoglycemic reaction.
That's one cause, another one would be you're
eating too much sugar, the third one would
be you're basically eating ... You're a diabetic
and you're taking medication that's too much,
you need to adjust that.
Hypoglycemia is very, very easy to correct
if you understand this right here.
I put some links down below of the eating
plan for, like, insulin resistance and things
like that.
But the point I want to make is instead of
going for that candy in your pocket, protein
would be the thing you need to do to drive
it up.
Then as far as a meal goes, to really correct
this even long-term, you don't want to have
snacks between the meal.
Now I know hypoglycemics need to eat between
the meals because their blood sugars crash.
Well a much better thing to do would be to
add a little fat with that meal, so you have
like a good amount of vegetables, protein
and fat.
Healthy fats like avocado, or coconut oil,
or even some animal fats if you're ... or
even butter.
The point is if you do that, that will not
spike insulin, it gets you to go longer, less
drops in blood sugars, and if you do that
consistently you can actually heal this whole
mechanism and completely not be hypoglycemic
anymore.
It's also good for hyperglycemia as well,
that's diabetes.
I wanted to mention this point about protein,
so stop having the candy in the pocket.
Don't do the glucose tablets.
They even have these little shakes you can
do of pure sugar.
You're never going to fix your problem that
way.
Do the protein, and put your comments below.
Thank you for watching.